[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE VAIS: We're going to be
talking about Firestore today.
My name is Natalie Vais,
and I'm a product manager
on Cloud Firestore.
I will be joined by my
colleague Ben Whitehead who's
on our developer relations
team, and he will come on stage
later on in the presentation.
So first I wanted to start
with a quick overview
of the session.
So the main goal
of this session is
for you to walk
away understanding
what Firestore is,
what it's good for,
and how you can integrate it
with other parts of the GCP
ecosystem.
For those of you who
are new to the product,
I'm going to start
with an introduction
and a history of the product.
I'll highlight some of the
new product announcements
that we made this
year as part of going
generally available in January.
I'll walk through some
of our example customer
architectures of people that are
using this in production today.
And then finally,
I'll give it over
to Ben who will walk you through
a demo demonstrating Firestore
in action.
We'll also leave some time at
the end of the session for Q&A.
And speaking of Q&A,
how we're actually
going to do it in
the session today
is using an application
called Dorie
which we use internally at
Google to manage Q&A at scale.
You can actually
find this through
your Next mobile application
for this session.
This will allow you
to submit questions
throughout the period
of this session.
And you can upvote and
downvote other peoples,
and I'll be using
that to moderate
at the end of the session.
So please feel free
to check that out.
So let's go ahead and dive into
an introduction to Firestore.
Before we jump
into that, I'd like
to get a bit of a sense of
the audience we have today.
How many of you out
there have actually
used Firestone already?
That's awesome.
Looks like 40%.
How about the real
time database?
Firebase Realtime Database.
OK.
Less of you.
And how about Cloud Datastore?
Cool.
Sounds good.
That's good background
for the session.
So Cloud Firestore is one
of many database offerings
that we have within
Google's cloud portfolio.
Here you can see a list of
all of the managed database
services.
Cloud Firestore is our NoSQL
document-oriented database,
making it part of our
non-relational offering.
And we'll talk about this
data model a little bit
later in the presentation.
I want to take a
step back briefly
and imagine that
you're trying to build
a mobile app for your company.
If you're starting a
project from scratch
and you want to
build it yourself,
you're likely going to have to
think about a couple of things.
Number one, setting
up a database,
which you'll probably have
to run and scale yourself
if you're taking
something off the shelf.
In front of that, you'll need
to put some sort of API layer
that can make queries
from your clients.
That probably means also
adding an authentication layer
so that you can make sure
that users that are accessing
your data are authenticated.
And this also means adding
some sort of sync logic
so that you can make sure you
make sure your data is syncing
with the local results.
And finally, these local
results are probably
going to be stored in a
completely separate client
database that again,
you have to make
sure is syncing
with your database
that we mentioned
up at the front.
Now when you arrive
here, all of a sudden you
have a pretty complex
set of solutions.
Each of these as a
standalone could actually
be a whole company in itself.
And that's what we
actually see today
is that people are having
to go to many vendors,
many different places, to
actually accomplish this stack
to build their
mobile or web apps.
And this is why we
built Firestore.
Firestore was built to
tackle these problems that
are very common to mobile
and web app development
and to simplify this
process for you.
For those that are familiar
with Cloud Datastore
and the Firebase
Realtime Database,
an important question is, how
does this relate to those?
Cloud Firestore is
the next generation
of cloud data storage.
And it includes
important learnings
from the Firebase
Realtime Database.
So we took a look at
the developer wishlists
from each of these,
and we used those
to inform the
decisions that we made
when built in Cloud Firestore.
So you can think of this
as the best of both worlds.
It takes some of the best
elements of Datastore
and some of the best
elements and learnings
from Firebase Realtime Database.
The first thing to know
is that Firestore is fully
supported in the Firebase SDKs.
This includes web,
iOS, and Android,
so you can access data
directly from the clients.
This is actually pretty
unusual for a database,
and it's not lost on us that
letting clients talk directly
to your database can pose
all sorts of challenges.
For one, you can't
always trust the data
that's coming from clients.
And secondly, you're dealing
with potentially unauthorized
users.
So this is where Firebase
Auth and security rules
come in handy.
These allow you to validate
operations from the client,
and this removes the need to
build that middle tier that you
saw on the previous
slide, which can sometimes
be its own standalone server
just to manage authentication.
Now the next thing
that's very important
is the ability to have
these applications
work across multiple
devices when we're
talking about client access.
Maybe you put down your
phone, you walk over
to your desktop
computer, and you
expect to resume the
same state in your app
that you're operating on.
So this is something that
Firestore handles natively,
and it makes it really, really
great for those applications
that you want to
develop and serve
to multiple types of
devices at one time.
Now another problem
that's very, very common
these days is people expect
their apps to work offline.
It's fairly normal
for people to look
at their mobile
applications when
there's little to no
chance of connectivity.
Maybe you're running
through the airport,
you're at the top of
a mountain, or maybe
you've gone offline on purpose.
So the same
technology that allows
us to operate in offline mode
also helps in the situations
where we have spotty
network connection.
And so as you can imagine, this
is very challenging to solve.
And we've actually built
this natively into Firestore.
It requires building complex
sync and conflict resolution
logic on the client.
So in Cloud Firestore,
our client libraries
come fully equipped to
handle these use cases.
So let's talk about the
data model in Firestore.
We've mentioned already that
Firestore is a document store.
So at the smallest
unit, the smallest unit
of storage in Firestore
is a document.
And a document, as you can
see up here on the screen,
is a lightweight record that
contains key value pairs.
There is no schema
enforcement in Firestore,
so you have complete
freedom over what
fields you put in a document.
Now documents can be grouped
together in related groups
that we call collections.
And you can see that
representation up here.
Documents can also map
to sub-collections,
and this lends itself really
nicely to hierarchical data
that's very common in web
and mobile app development.
So what we've seen so
far is that this model
works really, really
well for developers,
and is designed really
well to scale as well.
So let's talk about what's
new in Cloud Firestore.
As we mentioned,
called Firestore
went generally available
just earlier this year
at the end of January.
It was in beta for a little
over a year before that--
since 2017.
So as part of the announcement
of going generally available,
we have some pretty cool new
things that we've announced.
So the first thing
I want to mention
is that Cloud Firestore
operates in two different modes,
Datastore Mode and Native Mode.
These have slightly
different strengths
that I will highlight
based on the use case
that you're looking for.
So the first thing is
that Datastore Mode
has the exact same API and
same scale as Datastore,
but a new storage layer.
So if you are a
Datastore customer,
this will feel very
familiar to you.
And in fact, eventually, all
existing Datastore customers
will be able to upgrade to
Firestore and Datastore mode.
Datastore mode also
has some new things
that are greater than
some of the things offered
in Datastore today.
And those things include
strong consistency,
where we had eventually
consistent queries before
in Datastore.
We also have a higher
availability SLA, which
I'll talk about in a second.
And we also have a new
data flow connector.
So on the other side of
things, we have Native Mode.
And Native Mode leverages
this new document model,
and it integrates with
third party clients.
And that's kind of
the main difference.
And for those of you coming from
the Firebase Realtime Database
world, it's more
akin to the model
there with the
direct line access.
A simple way to
think about this is
that Datastore Mode is
optimized and scales really,
really well for your rights,
and Native Mode scales
really, really well for
concurrent connections.
So when you're thinking about
all these different clients
trying to connect to the
same application at once.
As part of going
generally available,
we also announced
10 new regions--
10 new locations that
are a combination
of multi-region and regional.
So you can see we have
two new regional--
sorry, two new
multi-regional locations
that are highlighted in green.
We have one in the
US and one in Europe.
And these multi-region
locations can actually
withstand the loss
of entire regions
because they're replicated
across more than one.
And this maintains availability
without losing data,
and all of these regions
are actually required
to be at least 100 miles apart.
In addition, we have new
service level agreements
that are attached to each
of these different types
of locations.
So the first for multi-region,
which is our highest SLA--
we have five nines availability.
And for regional, we
have four nines SLA.
Both of these are actually
improvements over the SLAs
that you saw in Datastore, which
were four nines and three nines
respectively.
And lastly, you can
access Firestore directly
from the Cloud Console.
Many of you who come from
the Realtime Database world
may know that you can
also access Firestore
from the Firebase Console.
And that's very common as well.
One of the things to
note about these UIs
is that they both operate
on the same projects.
So if you create a project
in the Cloud Console,
it's the same
project that you'll
see available in the
Firebase Console as well.
One of the benefits of using
the Google Cloud Console
is that you have access
to all the other GCB
products that I mentioned,
including things like BigQuery.
And that's something
that we're actually
going to showcase
later in the demo
is how to get some
of the data that's
in Firestore into BigQuery.
So let's walk through a
couple of customer examples.
Since we went GA, we've seen
a huge diversity of workloads
since launch, and some
of these were actually
some of our early beta customers
as well back from 2017.
So we have a lot
of customers that
span tons of
different industries,
but they do have a couple
of things in common.
The first is that a
lot of these companies
needed a really
quick time to market.
So they didn't want
to spend all this time
provisioning servers,
picking things off the shelf,
and stacking things together.
Second is that they
needed something
that would have the ability
to scale with their business.
They wanted the same
solution for their 10 users
that they want for
their 100,000, 1 million
user use case.
And the third thing is that
a lot of these companies
had really lean
development teams,
and they wanted to operate
in a serverless environment.
And as we know, Firestore
is a serverless environment.
You don't have to
think in terms of nodes
that you're provisioning or
capacity and resource planning.
In fact, the pricing is actually
built on an operational model
based on the reason rights
that you're actually
doing against the systems.
And this is huge, because
Firestore does not require
a massive team to run it.
And that's the beauty of it.
The same team that
gets you started
can actually carry you
through the scaling
of your application.
The first one of these customers
that I want to highlight
is a company called
Hawkin Dynamics.
They build sophisticated
hardware and software
for athletic
monitoring that's used
by several professional
sports teams.
So this hardware
that they develop
includes what you
can see up here
on the screen, which is
wireless force plates.
And these wireless force plates
measure the impact and movement
of athletes, and they
can track and measure
the performance
of these athletes
over time by capturing
this isometric data
in their application and
sending it back too Firestore.
Here's what their
architecture looks like.
They have the
wireless force plates
which capture and send the
data to the Hawkin Dynamics
mobile app.
This collects information across
athletes in many locations.
And because they're testing
facilities are often
in low-connectivity areas,
as you can imagine-- fields,
maybe they're doing
something at high altitude--
the ability to have
this offline sync
is very, very important to them.
So they can do their
tests, capture the data
for the athletes, have it
sent back to the application,
and then they have coaches
or other people that
are monitoring the athletic
statistics connecting
from other devices like
tablets and desktop computers
that can access this
information immediately.
So this is very
important to them.
And they've actually
been kind enough
to share their data models.
So we can drill into a little
bit of how they've actually
modeled their business using the
Cloud Firestore document model.
So what you'll see up is a top
level collection called teams.
Each of this collection
contains documents,
one of each corresponding
to each of their teams.
And these teams have
sub-collections.
And these
sub-collections, you can
see some of them listed here.
It can include
settings, raw force
data that's collected from the
force plates, different tests.
If we drill in a level further,
they also a sub-collection
called Athletes.
So here there's a document
for every one of the athletes
that they're collecting
this information on.
And here they can drill
into all the tests
that have been
captured or performed
for that athlete over time.
The next customer that
I want to highlight
is one that you actually
may be familiar with.
There's a high chance that
you went to this website
because you're all
here today, or that you
accessed the mobile app.
So our developer friends
over at the Nerdery--
I think we have some of them
potentially in the audience.
There.
So they are a
digital consultancy
that actually helped build the
conference web and mobile apps
for us using Cloud Firestore.
So they use Firestore
as an aggregation hub
for all of the
conference data that's
serving the session information,
the breakouts, et cetera.
And again, we actually
have a data model
to show you and
see how this works.
So here you can see
an actual document
that represents content that's
being served to the next home
page.
And in this case, it's
the mobile app page.
So you can see the
content being served here.
It also has static content
that's being stored elsewhere.
And you can see the path
to that information here.
If I click to the
next, this is actually
a high level collection
representing all
of the different next event.
So the one that's
highlighted right now
is the one that you're in here
today for, which is Next SF.
You'll also see entries here
for the future next event
that we have in
Tokyo and London.
And here is actually the
session we're in right now.
So this document
represents the session ID.
You can see here
we have information
about the session type, the
different related fields--
so these are sessions
it recommends
you go to if you also
have gone to this one--
and then speaker ID, which
refer to both Ben and myself.
Something that's not on
the screen that also exists
in the app is a
field lower down that
tells the capacity of
each of the sessions.
So you can imagine if
the capacity is full,
it will no longer let
someone register for that.
So when you first visit the
conference site, what you're
seeing is a session
and speaker information
that's being loaded
from Firestore,
as well as some of these static
images and assets from Google
Cloud Storage.
When you sign in with
either your Google account
or personal email
address, you're
actually hitting
Firebase Auth which
is authenticating you
and making sure you have
the proper account and
you have access to all
the information you're seeing.
Then when you register for
a session like this one
that you're in today, the
app makes an API call out,
it updates the
information in Firestore,
and immediately updates that
information to the user.
So next what I want to
do is invite Ben onstage.
Now that you've seen
some customer examples,
I want him to
actually demonstrate
Firestore for you in action.
Thank you, Natalie.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN WHITEHEAD: I
am Ben Whitehead.
I'm a developer
programs engineer
with Google Cloud focusing
on Cloud Firestore and Cloud
Datastore.
So I'm going to be
running through a demo
today showing how we've got
a demo app built leveraging
the real time functionality
of Cloud Firestore,
as well as some of the
larger suite of GCP
to handle doing analytics
tasks to kind of help
the business understand
how your app is behaving.
So first, we're going to look
at a couple of architecture
diagrams just to give
a high level view,
and then we'll dig into
some of the details.
So here we've got a high level
architecture diagram of the app
that we're going to be
demoing and analyzing
today called Firepixels.
In the little mobile
icon, you can kind of
see that there are
four colored quadrants.
This is actually the
Firestore logo colored
using the Google colors.
So each of these
respective quadrants
is made up of 10,000 pixels.
And each of those
10,000 pixels are backed
by a document in Firestore.
So in Firestore, we
actually have a document
for every single pixel
that's maintaining
the color of that pixel,
the last updated timestamp,
as well as a
partition that we're
using to parallelize the
event propagating to the UI
that we'll be able to see in
the real-time demo in just
a few minutes.
So given that there are the
four quadrants, each of them
have 10,000, this can handle
up to 40,000 concurrent users,
essentially kind of
poking at the bits
to represent each of the pixels.
So we've got a
simulation service
running on GKE that's
actually running
a simulation of
some user activity,
so you will be seeing
pixels kind of updating
when we get over to the demo.
So we've got this
application up and running.
We've gained a fair
amount of user traction.
And the business comes
over to us and says, great.
You've got this thing.
We need to start
getting some numbers.
And because you were
very quick to market,
that probably didn't mean that
you baked all of your analytics
into your app from the get-go.
So how do you reinforce and
get information for your users?
So the particular
business questions
that we're going to
be answering today
are, what are the number
of distinct color events
that have happened over
the past 30 minutes,
over the past 2 days,
and over the past 7 days?
The next question is,
what are the number
of distinct colors that
occurred in the last minute
for the past 30 minutes?
And finally, we're
going to have a chart
that we are going to use
to monitor the ingestion
latency of how long it's
actually taking to process
these events from user
actions to it being
available in the data warehouse.
So this is a high level
architecture diagram
essentially expanding
on what components we're
going to be looking at today.
So on the left hand
side, the yellow box--
it's a little faint.
Sorry about that-- the left hand
box represents the same side
that we just saw previously.
So we can see here,
Cloud Firestore
is sort of the bridging
point into the rest of GCP
that we're going to be
integrating with today.
And we're going
to specifically be
using Cloud Functions to
monitor change events on each
of the pixel documents
inside the database.
When each of those
events is triggered,
we're going to
handle that event,
process it, and feed that
into BigQuery that will then
be used to generate some
predefined views to feed charts
inside Data Studio
so that we can put up
a dashboard in our office for
everybody to able to look at.
And since Cloud
Functions are these kind
of magic, ephemeral
things, we need
to have some monitoring for us.
So we're going to
leverage Stackdriver
to do essentially
metrics monitoring
and invocations per second,
and those sorts of things
over time.
Can we switch to the
demo laptop, please?
OK, great.
Over here on the left hand side,
this is the Firepixels app.
This is a real time app.
This is running,
hitting Firestore.
We can see each of the four
colored quadrants currently
of--
oh, look.
Cool.
Our simulation just kicked in.
That bottom left
quadrant was updated.
And we've got a number
of document listeners
on the back end that are
listening for those simulation
events.
So that was just 10,000 writes
to the database and the events
being triggered, audited,
sent to the back end,
as well as aggregated
and then sent down
to the web client
over web sockets.
So it's very responsive.
It can give you a great
experience for your users.
And we'll be able to see
that changing over time
during the rest of
the presentation.
So first, we're
going to jump over
to Cloud Firestore in
the Google Console,
and we're going to take a look
into the data model that's
actually backing the Firepixels
app right now on the left hand
side.
So here on the left
hand column, we've
got three different collections,
top level collections.
One for devices, one for
input, and one for pixels.
The collection for devices--
this is actually a
heartbeat collection.
So for each of the
respective clients that
are managing each
of those pixels
as part of the simulation,
we're essentially
tracking the heartbeat of the
last time one of those users
actually did something for us.
If we move down to
the inputs collection,
we can see a 0 through 3.
The 0 through 3 here represent
each of the colored quadrants
over on the left hand side,
starting top to bottom,
left to right.
Excuse me.
Left to right, top to bottom.
So 0, 1, 2, 3.
In each of those documents,
we can see the color.
We can also see the updated
timestamp of the last time
that quadrant was updated.
And if we look at the
pixels collection,
here we can see a list
of the 40,000 documents
that represent
each of the pixels.
So the name of the document
that we've got here
is essentially 3
digits dash 3 digits.
This is representing the
xy coordinate in the grid.
And we can see the color
for that particular pixel,
which partition that
pixel is associated with,
and the last updated timestamp.
So while the
simulation is running--
wow, we got it all blue.
That's really unusual--
let's take the top right
and let's change
this to be yellow.
So I can hit that.
That's going to
trigger the events.
All of the event
handlers on the backside
are going to observe
that particular part
of the simulation.
They're then going
to update each
of their respective
pixel documents.
And then, again, that's going
to be aggregated to the back end
and sent over to the UI.
So you can kind of see
how quick and responsive
that is, even from an
administrative standpoint.
From there, let's jump back over
to the Google Cloud Console.
A quick overview here--
the Google Cloud
Console is trying
to help you out and
surface information
that's relevant to you based on
how your project is behaving.
So for our project, we are using
Compute Engine to run our GKE
cluster for our simulations.
We've got some GCS buckets,
Google Cloud Storage buckets
for storing some static assets.
We can also see that we're
using Cloud Functions.
We currently have one
function that's deployed.
And we've got one data set in
BigQuery, which is ultimately
the data warehouse
data set that we're
going to be working with today.
And we can also see a quick
overview of the number API
requests, as well as compute
engine CPU processing.
The API requests--
this is aggregated
across all of the various
back end products in GCP.
So this can give you a good
idea of how much of GCP
you're using without
necessarily having to build
up a big graph all yourself.
So for here, let's start
from Cloud Functions.
So I'm going to open up
a new tab real quick.
This is the single
Cloud Function
that we have active right now.
If you had more
Cloud Functions, they
would show up in this list.
You get a quick
overview of what region
the function is running in.
This is important
for data locality
just in terms of
latency of processing.
It's also becoming
increasingly more important due
to regulatory
restrictions around data
egress and migrations,
and those sorts of things.
The trigger type
of the function.
So there are many types
of triggers that you
can use with Cloud Functions.
Today, we're using
Cloud Firestore.
You can also use it with
Google Cloud Storage when
a new document is
created or other sorts
of things like that.
We're, for this example,
we're using Node.js version 8.
This is convenient.
It gives us the
async await handles.
So it makes our code a little
bit more terse, which is nice.
I've given this function
blindly 256 megabytes of RAM.
I seriously doubt I'm using
that much, so I should probably
knock it down to
save on some billing.
But, you know, I haven't
been harassed about that yet,
so we'll worry about it later.
And then the function
inside our code
that's going to be called
as part of the event handler
is called On Pixel Change.
And we can see the last time
that this code was deployed.
So let's click in here and
load up some of the details.
When we click into
each of the functions,
we get to a high
level overview showing
the number of
invocations per seconds
where we can kind of see
success, failure, error rates--
those sorts of things,
just in high level view.
This little peak that we notice
on the right hand side, this
is when I manually change
the value in the database
a couple of minutes ago.
Those events got
processed immediately.
So that's higher than the normal
simulation is normally doing.
You can see that you can
get some different time
granularities.
But ultimately,
this information is
bounded to what time
boundaries you have here.
So for longer term storage
and monitoring and alerting,
we'll leverage
Stackdriver for that
and we'll get to that
in just a minute.
So scrolling down a
little bit, one thing
that's not shown
on the summary page
is this service
account down here.
The service account is
actually very important.
So the service account gives
your function an identity
as far as access
controls and security are
concerned in the greater GCP.
So when I'm integrating
with BigQuery,
the identity of next IO
storage service account
is given the permission
to write into BigQuery.
So if you've got many
projects or many teams,
you can do fine-grain controls
to where you could say,
this function is able to write
to this thing in BigQuery,
but this other function is
only able to interact with GCS.
So it gives you
that kind of control
to be able to handle multiple
things at the same time.
So jumping over
here to the trigger,
we saw the trigger type
earlier is Cloud Firestore.
The particular event type
that we're caring about right
now is update.
There is also the Create
and Delete, as well as
just general Right.
So this can be really nice
from an auditing standpoint,
or doing data ingestion
for analytics,
as we're doing today.
Without having to do
modifications to your database
or to your app,
you can essentially
hook up monitoring and
those sorts of things.
And then the resource
path right here.
So if you remember
back here in Firestore,
we've got our pixels collection.
If you think of this as sort of
like a directory structure that
matches with the
document collection,
sub-collection document
sort of pattern, right now,
essentially, I'm specifying
a directory structure that
says underneath the
pixels collection,
I want to match on any pixel.
So inside curly
brace is essentially
like a variable placeholder.
So over here on the Source tab--
I'll pull this up for folks.
So this massive 30 lines of
code is the sum total of code
that you need to be able to
get an event from the Cloud
Function into BigQuery.
So the BigQuery
node module-- we're
able to just import up here the
data set that we're inserting
to, the table that
we're inserting to,
and we're creating the BigQuery
client right here on line 5.
You'll notice there's
no credential passing
or, hey, load up this thing,
or anything like that.
The default constructor
for the clients
is defaulted to using
the service account.
So if you're running
something on Cloud Functions
or you're running something
on App Engine or GCP,
the environment is essentially
bootstrapped for you
already to use the service
account information
that you've configured
through the cloud API.
So moving down a little
bit, lines 7 through 26
are the full function.
At line 8 and 9,
we're essentially
pulling out the time 0 values.
And then on line 9, we're
pulling out the time 1 values.
And then we're constructing
our data structure
that we want to
send to BigQuery.
So that's the pixel
that's being modified--
essentially the pre and post
values, as well as the process
time when this is actually being
processed and sent to BigQuery.
Then on line 21 is where
we're doing the actual write
to BigQuery, and our
function is effectively done.
We do have a console
log statement here.
I should have cleaned this up.
It's not actually doing anything
useful for us at this point.
But the logs that I
write to the console here
are actually available
in Stackdriver.
So if you're setting up your
function and you're like,
hey, did I actually
get the data there,
or I'm kind of curious
what the events look
like, that sort of stuff, you
can do your printf, console log
inspection, and all that
information shows up
in Stackdriver.
OK.
So jumping back to the
Cloud Console real quick.
From here-- pardon me.
I actually skipped Stackdriver.
So let's pull up
Stackdriver first.
So Stackdriver, if
folks aren't familiar,
is the kind of user-side
monitoring hub for your apps
and usage of GCP on GCP.
So here, we can see
essentially a metric graph.
It looks very similar to
the overview-- excuse me--
the overview that we had product
back on the function page.
But it does give you the ability
to do broader time spans.
So we can actually look back
and see the development work
that picked up in
the middle of the May
for this particular demo.
You can even do custom
frames if you wanted to,
as well as real-time
dashboards if this is something
that you want to put
in your team's bullpen
or something like that.
So let's jump back
down to an hour.
So right now, we've got
three different charts.
So we're tracking the number
of executions of our Cloud
Function per second.
In the case of Stackdriver,
this is being aggregated up
to per-minute buckets.
So we can see over time.
Again, that little peak when I
manually changed the database.
Scrolling down, we can see the
Cloud Function instance count.
So this is one of
the things that's
really powerful about Cloud
Functions is it essentially
takes care of all of the
scaling factors for you.
So by us triggering
events and events being in
cued to be processed,
GCP figures out
how many functions it
needs to scale up for you,
and when they can be able
to scale down, and back up,
and those sorts of things.
So that's why you're
seeing some spikiness this
is when it's scaling down,
it's trying to save me money.
When it scaling back up, I'm
giving it more work to do.
The final chart
down at the bottom
is a pretty cool little chart
that Stackdriver provides
which gives you a heat map.
So instead of having to look
at you're 7 lines for your P50
and P95 and all
that stuff, it'll
actually just render
a heat graph for you.
So we can see here
that most of our events
are processing in
about 100 milliseconds.
This little hot spot down
here when I did the manual
trigger again.
But this is nice,
because you can
start to see things over time.
If we were to expand
this to the last week,
we can see that it's been
running relatively consistent.
We've had a couple
high latency pokes
at a couple different
point in times.
But nothing super concerning,
as they've come back down.
And it looks like our peaks
are about 5 seconds or so.
So jumping back to
the Cloud Console,
from here we're going
to jump into BigQuery
and take a look at the data set.
So this is the schema
of the pixel tables.
You notice it looks exactly
like the JSON document
we looked at in the function.
Unlike Firestore,
BigQuery is schema'd.
But this is to help out
with query planning and just
the dynamic nature in
analytics, and the fact
that it's SQL-oriented.
So we click on Preview.
We can actually see a
summary of some of the data
that's in there.
So for pixel 66, comma, 103,
we changed from red to blue,
partition stayed
the same, and then
we got the respective
timestamps.
This all supports your standard
SQL that you're familiar with.
So I could do select star
from the Cloud Console.
Also has nice auto
completion for you,
which is really great,
because inevitably you
end up getting long names,
and historical names,
and all that stuff.
Let's see.
Order by.
T1 updated.
Descending Limit 10.
And we can hit Go, and
it will essentially
just start crunching.
So in our full
database so far, we've
got something like 600
million events that have been
stuck in our data warehouse.
And that's in the span
of about two weeks.
So as apps get more
IoT and user-intensive,
you can imagine
having a database that
can scale out and give you quick
queries is really valuable.
And that's what we're
getting from BigQuery.
So we're going to jump down here
and look at a view real quick.
So the views that
we've got defined here
are essentially what we're using
to drive the charts that I'll
show you in just a second.
You can see that they're
kind of standard SQL.
Select, From, Table,
Group By, Ordering,
Limits, all that
same, normal stuff.
So you're not having to
learn a brand new charting
library or anything like that.
You can just write
your SQL statements
and then load that
up in your dashboard.
So I'll jump over here to
the Firepixels dashboard.
So this is a dashboard that
I've created in Data Studio.
One of the things that's
really nice about Data Studio
dashboards is it fully
integrates with all of your G
Suite organization structure.
So this dashboard that
I'm showing you right now
is actually shared to my demo
user from my main work user.
So this is really
nice if you need
to put it on a display
in your bullpen,
or if you only want to share
it with maybe your manager
before it's published to
the rest of the company,
you've got full ACL control
the same way that you
do with Google Docs.
So here on the top row, we
can see three different charts
with color breakdowns.
So these color breakdowns
are answering the questions
that we mentioned at the
beginning of the demo
around the business questions.
So the business question
is essentially, how many--
or, excuse me--
for the top row is,
what is the ratio of a
particular color per time
bucket over a period of time?
So here we're saying for the
last 30 minutes, about 63%
of the color changes were to
blue, and the other 37% or so
were to yellow.
So this makes it really
easy to look at the chart.
And having some context around
the way that the app behaves,
you can just kind of
look at it and get
an idea of what the
app probably looked
like at that point in time.
And then that expands
to two days ago,
as well as over the past week.
In the bottom left
we've got our line chart
that's showing the
number of distinct colors
that were changed
to in that frame.
So here we can see that we
had two that we changed to.
One time we only had one.
One time we actually got
all the way up to three.
You know, just various
interesting things.
And then the center chart is
showing our ingestion latency.
So this is essentially
showing in seconds
how long it's taking
from the document being
written into Firestore for
us to write it into BigQuery.
So this is
essentially showing us
an end-to-end latency of getting
data into our data warehouse.
So the vast majority are being
handled in less than 2 seconds.
And we've got a little
bit of plateau here.
This is actually I
believe due to the fact
that the Cloud
Functions are spinning
back up after being
spun down between stages
of the simulation running.
And then there's almost a
full drop off by the time
we reach 7 seconds.
So the vast, vast majority
of all of our events
are being put into our data
warehouse in 8 seconds or so.
[MUSIC PLAYING]